este edificio sobrevivió al terremoto
del 6 de febrero dos semanas después se
ha derrumbado tras el doble seísmo que
sacudió la provincia de hatay los
residentes sintieron un primer temblor
de magnitud 6,4 el segundo se produjo 3
minutos después sembrando el terror en
el sur de Turquía y el noroeste de Siria
estaba delante del edificio la carretera
se movía como las olas el edificio se
movía iba de un lado a otro los coches
iban de izquierda a derecha nos hizo
perder el equilibrio
tras una serie de terremotos en las
últimas semanas los lugareños saben que
es mejor huir de sus hogares Y Buscar
seguridad al aire libre en lugar de
permanecer en edificios que ya no
parecen seguros
lo mismo ocurre en el noroeste de Siria
aquí en asas varias familias Se han
refugiado en sus vehículos o en espacios
abiertos
estábamos tranquilos en casa rezar
cuando sentí que el suelo temblaba
salimos corriendo solo cogimos una
alfombra y mantas para mantener
calientes a los niños
el Ministerio del interior Turco ya ha
confirmado varias muertes y cientos de
personas han resultado heridas tanto en
Turquía como en Siria Mientras tanto el
número de víctimas mortales de los
terremotos iniciales del 6 de febrero
sigue aumentando y supera los 47.000